the section 31 movie let's have a chat
about it welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and move your Channel
[Music]
Michelle yo is going to be appearing in
a section 31 TV movie and I'm quite
excited about it I love Michelle yeah I
love the Giorgio character and I cannot
wait to see what they come up with
but the road to this point has not been
as clear or as well planned as Alex
kurtzman's spin machine would like us to
believe now I have talked about this in
other videos but at the end of the day
the plan was always for section 31
series when Michelle yeoh left Star Trek
Discovery to go through the gate of the
guardian of forever the idea was for a
series but then Michelle yo got several
big projects including and most
importantly the Avatar Series so then
they started talking about a mini series
kind of like what she did with the
Witcher that terrible one that a
Christmas that was got awful she was
great in it
but it was awful
sort of like that so maybe five maybe
six episodes as a one-off you know but
four to six hours of television
then Michelle yo won the Oscar
and they had to scrap the whole thing
and that to start again and they had to
renegotiate now my source is actually
telling me that Alex Kurt was kind of
pinning a lot of his ideas for the
future this phase two of Star Trek on
getting Michelle yo there are people at
Paramount that question what um they've
done at secret hideout with Star Trek
look that shouldn't really be a shock to
anybody there are people within our fan
base that question it so of course there
are going to be Executives and creative
people over at Paramount that do too but
those people those critics have really
been silenced by this announcement now
it has been kind of spun a little bit
that this movie idea was over a year ago
I could tell you it wasn't this movie
idea was actually finalized about two
months ago just after the Oscar and was
actually only signed and agreed on April
6th it was supposed to be signed and
agreed a couple of days before that but
there was a bit of a cock-up they wanted
to announce this on April 5th on First
Contact Day it got announced a week
later simply because the contracts
hadn't been agreed so this was not the
plan and this idea of maybe doing
several TV movies was not the plan it is
now so let's talk about it well
I I have immediate concerns already
right so they had a plan for a series
maybe 10 episodes so 10 hours of
Television maybe multiple seasons of the
section 31 idea they then thought well
we can't really do that how about we
just do a one-off maybe four maybe six
hours of Television we've got a story
idea for that
now they've got to do two hours pretty
much at most that's all they're gonna
get so we're gonna have to have this
story idea that they had when Giorgio
left discovering the idea that they had
at that point for this section 31
project that's been bouncing around for
ages is now going to have to be boiled
down from
10 hours down to six hours down to two
hours that basically means they're going
to have to go back to the drawing board
and start having a complete rethink
about what they're actually going to do
with this because
it's complicated already obviously when
we last Saw Michelle Yo's Giorgio she
was stepping through the guardian of
forever that's how you won't fall apart
atomically speaking
consider yourself lucky you're getting a
second shot that's pretty unique but it
won't be easy
she had been tested by Carl the guardian
to see whether she would have a positive
or A negative influence on whatever
Universe she then went through she was
actually dying because of all the
different time periods and galaxies and
universes that she'd existed in her
molecules are literally getting ripped
apart by it so the guardian akar sent it
back to a point in time where the Mirror
Universe and the prime Universe still
existed in alignment so she could
survive
now we don't know exactly when that time
frame is going to be but obviously it's
going to be where the movie is set now
let's think about section 31 a little
bit the Dark Side of Starfleet
intelligence the part of Starfall
intelligence that are willing to do
whatever it takes regardless of who gets
hurt killed genocide whatever to get the
job done and protect the Federation I'm
learning to really like starfleeting and
section 31. do you think they'll give
you a free rate
that place has eyes on eyes on eyes well
it's a good thing I do some of my best
work in plain sight they are really the
bad guys you know this because they
always wear black I'm amazed everyone
got goatees or evil mustaches or
something they should do they consider
themselves to be the side of Starfall
intelligence of the part of the
Federation that's necessary the dirty
side of the Federation the Federation
wants to have high values it wants to
live in a utopian society it wants to
always do the right thing
but section 31 understands that that's
not always possible and when the really
tough decisions need to get made section
31 are the ones to step up and do it how
would Giorgio fit in with that well
Giorgio kind of has that attitude as
well she was obviously a villain when we
first saw her but she softened she began
to understand her role in the universe
in a different way and we got to see by
the end a Giorgio that actually instead
of being just the empress could actually
be a positive influence on the universe
but she is still willing to do the hard
thing and she is still willing to kill
to solve problems if she thinks it's
necessary
she really is a little bit of an
anti-hero and that's why we've got a
lover right it's I'm sure it's why
Michelle yo is so desperate to do this
because she must be glorious to play
Giorgio is just such a brilliant
character anyway
so obviously Giorgio is going to end up
being a very now
now Empress Georgia is a very
intelligent character we saw that in the
future episodes of Discovery I remember
the bit where she's been interviewed by
the two Holograms and she does the
blinking thing to freak her out and
break them basically
she's a master manipulator she is a
master at the Mind Games she actually
would be the perfect spy or even lead of
section 31 because you actually actually
imagine her being like a spy and having
a Handler whoever tried to handle
Giorgio that's going to be a full-time
job so yeah I could see her trying to
position herself to you know maximize
her Authority quite early on the movie
is obviously still probably going to be
based on the original story idea at
least vaguely there will be some sort of
problem within the Federation section 31
will get involved Giorgio will find
herself in the middle of it and I
imagine all hell will break loose this
is not going to be a cinematic release
which is a shame it is actually going to
be a straight to Paramount plus release
even though I have actually been told by
several people remembering that Michelle
yeoh has just won an Oscar don't be
shocked if Paramount decided to try to
push this for a cinema release
um that's not the plan at the moment but
that's just their opinion if you do know
it's going in pre-production probably
the end of this year and it will
hopefully be on the screens by the end
of 2024 or early 2025. I'm told that the
budget may be something around the 40 to
50 million dollar region which
frustrates a TV movie is still pretty
good good so what do I actually think
about this project
well anything Michelle you're in for
years I've been a fan of she's an
insanely beautiful woman she's a
brilliant actress and she could kick
most of our asses I've actually argued a
couple of times on this channel that if
they bring Highlander back in a new
movie Henry Cavill should be the
Highlander and that was the plan for a
long time but Michelle yeoh should play
Ramirez
um I know a lot of people don't like the
gender swapping thing but from a
storyline point of view
the Highlander was destroyed when Sean
Connery's Ramirez was killed because he
was like a father figure but what's
worse than losing a father figure losing
a mother figure and I just think it
would be funny to see Michelle yo beat
in Henry Cavill up I just think it'd be
funny so yes I am a big fan and I love
her and everything so on that respect I
can't wait for this
I am concerned about how the plan has
changed now three times generally in the
past when we've seen big projects like
this getting boiled down and changed and
the direction changed they tend to get
confused they tend to try to then put
too much in because there'll be elements
from what they would do in previously
that will find their way into the new
project and generally speaking
it's a concern from that respect I'm
also being told that Alex kurtzman will
not actually be allowed to
um direct and have a major influence in
this movie The Paramount is kind of
negotiating quite hard with him that
he's going to be concentrating on
Starfleet Academy and that somebody else
possibly Ronald D Moore
maybe would be brought in to write and
produce and maybe direct the project
now if that's true that makes me very
happy but the main reason apparently if
you believe some of the more negative
rumors that are coming out of them
secret hi that empowerment Plus
that actually the reason why Coachmen
pushed this so hard was he actually has
Ambitions Beyond Star Trek and that
directing Oscar winning Michelle yo
wouldn't have hurt those Ambitions at
all
he may not get that opportunity because
Paramount would prefer to go with
somebody else give the comments and tell
me what you think about the section 31
movie is it something you're looking
forward to are you concerned about this
change in direction are you concerned if
Alex kurtzman did get the director's
chair
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the channel like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us enter
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos end up first and for a small
contribution that really support the
channel each month you can see them
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign